so we got a tip from a friend
that there is vaccines here in the hans
loma
and they're vaccinating people under 50
so
we thought to give it a try these young
middle-aged people
don't have an appointment but they've
come to this clinic in tel aviv
hoping to get vaccinated against covert
19. i was really nervous to get
vaccinated
and we got it while in most countries
around the world
you have to be part of a priority to be
vaccinated israeli clinics have been
giving out any remaining doses to the
general public
after the day's scheduled appointments
end for priority patients
this strategy is one of the reasons
israel vaccinated a greater share of its
population than any other country more
than 20 percent in just a few weeks
way ahead of the us and european
countries that also have much larger
populations
the country hopes to immunize a majority
of its population
by early spring right now what we see is
a race
on one hand we have the virus spread
spiraling out of control on the other
hand
we have the vaccination campaign going
very quickly
weeks after the program started demand
was so high
some clinics had no extra doses left at
the end of the day and sometimes
turned people away
it's always good to try your chances and
that's why i hope but
sometimes you get unlucky but there
there's always a tomorrow
we wanted to know how does israel's
program work exactly
netanyahu announced that israel had
secured enough doses of the faisal bio
and tech shot
to vaccinate everyone over 16 by the end
of march
although this max vaccination campaign
alone is unlikely to eradicate the virus
this timeline sets israel apart as other
western nations have fallen behind
schedule
in the u.s the vaccination of the
elderly and essential workers alone
is expected to take several more weeks
one reason israel has been able to
vaccinate so much of its population so
quickly
is that it's a relatively small country
with a population similar to that
of new york city israel has transformed
stadiums
and other venues into max vaccination
centers israel also has a
technologically advanced
universal health care system in which
everyone in the country
is legally required to be registered
unlike the us where there's a patchwork
of public and private coverage israel's
digitized system
has helped streamline the process for
those who have an appointment
including high risk and priority
patients over 60.
every member set an appointment in
advance and
it's already scheduled for two
appointments for the first dose and the
second those 21
days later now he comes here and the
exact time and hour that we asked him to
come
he uses card and um pulls out a number
and then someone will take him to one of
the stations
and in the station the nurse will
document everything
his name his id and the
number of the bottle and even in which
of the arms is going to get the
vaccination
and then she will do the vaccination and
he will
wait for about 15 minutes at the other
side of this compound
at the start of the vaccination campaign
iso's program ran into big issues
and many vaccine vials had to be thrown
away
israel bought 8 million doses from
pfizer paying a premium for early
shipments
as well as 6 million vaccines for
moderna and 10 million from astrazeneca
when the pfizer vaccine first arrived in
israel hundreds of doses had to be
dumped
due to lower than expected turnout
that's because the biointex fizer
vaccine
must be administered within five days
after leaving the main storage facility
where it must be kept at ultra cold
temperatures as low as -112 degrees
fahrenheit
after the vaccine dump authorities began
dividing some vaccine packages into
smaller shipments for more isolated
areas
making for more efficient distribution
professor balerser
is the chief innovation officer for
clelit israel's largest healthcare
organization
and he's helped advise the israeli
government on his vaccine strategy
we have given the full permission to
every delivery point
once they get to the point in which the
tray of
vials is about to uh become a need for
destruction because of the time limits
in the
code chain requirements they are not
only allowed
we want them to go ahead find anyone
bring them in
and put a shot in the arm so no vaccine
would go to waste
the vaccines are now in high demand and
thanks to the latest shipment of
vaccines
the country is set to start opening up
new appointments to even more people
i think one of the key challenges we
have right now is we have no means to
get vaccines to the houses of people who
are bedridden
and cannot leave their home what we've
tried to do until now was to vaccinate
their
key caregivers the vaccination program
comes at a critical time for israel
which early in 2021 had one of the
world's highest infection rates and
fatalities were on the rise
as it entered a third lockdown there's
also the challenge of vaccine acceptance
with ongoing skepticism over the shots
and government initiatives
in some parts of the population still
here in tel aviv many people have shown
up hoping to get vaccinated
as soon as possible i came here tonight
to
trying to get the scene for the coffee
and i want to
travel see world and
starting my life like i wanted to and
not to
stay out in 14 in my house